uh we'd like to welcome in an MVP for
the Phoenix Suns one Hall of Famer
Charles Barkley and Chuck Manson's Matt
ishma took over with your uh Phoenix
Suns the owner this team has been busy
busy busy so what do you make of the
Phoenix Suns getting involved in this
Damian Lillard trade
well uh I'm not totally shocked I'm
shocked that he went to Milwaukee
uh so obviously Milwaukee should be to
bed in favorites now
you know it's clear to the sun's had
something was going on with uh with with
DeAndre Hayden and you know it goes back
to that was an issue with money Williams
and Deandre
and now clearly it must have been
something else going on in the
organization they clearly just want to
get rid of him but the big winner uh is
the Milwaukee Bucks
and uh who are their general manager
they got a new coach he's a young guy uh
on uh I forget his name Adrian Adrian
yep Adrian Griffin yep yeah Adrian is a
man he's got a great team to start
you know I I like what the Celtics did
going out getting porzingis but I think
it's fair to say that the Milwaukee
Bucks are the favorite going into the
season to win NBA championship
and Chuck with that being said what is
the biggest message for Adrian Griffin
knowing that Dane was a star in Portland
Giannis is used to having the ball in
his hands late late game situation what
is that message for both guys to buy
into wee ball because it used to be a
meatball late game situations
well I think it can benefit both guys uh
because number one famous always had to
do everything by himself
so it's going to be nice for him to play
with somebody number one that's don't
believe out Chris Middleton so I think
it's going to be beneficial to both guys
you know Giannis I think the one thing
he's gonna have to learn to do and I
thought I've always thought it was the
one weakness of his game he's got to
learn to play without the basketball
it's going to make the game easier for
him you know he used to bring it up
going downhill now if he'd get out on
that Wing I think he's gonna get a lot
more easier a basket uh in the in the
full court in the half court him and
Dane man and Chris I mean you think
about it when they won the championship
they'll pick and roll was Chris
Middleton and Giannis now he's gonna
have Giannis and Dame man that is gonna
be explosive so Giannis I think is going
to really help him but it's gonna
definitely help danger he ain't gonna
have to do it all by himself he's gonna
have two guys not one he's gonna have
two guys they can get a ball too and he
don't in Portland anytime you know you
go back and look at Portland every Big
Shot they've had the last five or seven
to ten years has been him making a Hail
Mary from half court
now he could make that shot but now he
gonna have Giannis and Chris Middleton
so man it's a great day for the
Milwaukee Bucks and I'm not upset with
what the sons did I mean obviously they
already made a big move going out
getting Bradley Bill
I think they're probably well I don't
want to say they're the favorite in the
west because man I love what the Lakers
have done I mean you take your head off
to what the Lakers have done this summer
I think them and the sons are the two
favorites because I really think
the Nuggets lost some good players man I
do I think if nuggets lost some good
players I don't want to disrespect the
Champs but if you ask me going in I
think the Lakers and the suns are the
two favorites in the west and the East
is the Celtics and the Milwaukee Bucks
you know Chuck it sounds like you're
buying the Bucks that's what I keep
hearing from you as you keep going down
this list but there's something I often
hear you talk about especially when you
say Championship caliber teams right and
it's those guys I mean the guys that win
you championships and it feels like
Milwaukee went from Giannis was the guy
to now it's Giannis Dame and you're
saying even Chris Middleton can be in on
that conversation can you explain how
that could be true
well because you know you go back and
look at the game that Milwaukee lost
Giannis missed 17 free throws
he's not gonna have to do that anymore
I mean he's great he's him and Joker in
my opinion had two best players in the
world but he missed 17 free throws in
that elimination game people are
glossing over that he can't miss you
can't have your best player missing 17
free throws but now with Dame and Chris
he ain't gonna have to take 17 free
throws so they're they're like I say
it's going to benefit everybody you know
because you go back and look at the year
they won that championship
he after one game where he made like
17 out of 20 free throws
but that was that was an anomaly that
wasn't what he does specifically in that
game five when they lost to the Heat
last year he missed like 17 free throws
hey Chuck what do you say to the the
naysayers that what Drew holiday brought
to the team defensively decision making
down the stretch how do they replace
that or is Dame Superstar power overcome
that
well a couple of things these got uh
when they won a championship
those plays first of all I love Drew
holiday he's a great defender and a hell
of a player but the year the Milwaukee
Bucks won the championship Chris
Middleton they would go into him because
you know Giannis was struggling at the
free-throw line you know he had that one
game against assassins where he went
crazy but if you go back them getting to
the finals they always went to Chris
Middleton they wasn't going to Drew
holiday as much as I loved Drew holiday
but you factor in
the Dame is not as good defensively as
Drew holiday but Drew holiday is not as
good offensively as him so it's kind of
a wash but if you ask yourself this
man for the thing that the thing that
shocked me the most about this thing B
Scott I have no idea what my 76ers were
doing I was like they're like we're not
gonna give up we're not going to give up
Maxie I said wait a minute so you're
telling me the Milwaukee Bucks gave up
Drew holiday who's a hell of a player
right and the circles are like we're not
giving up Maxi I love Maxi but if I'm if
I'm the Milwaukee Bucks I'm telling you
this is what I think they were thinking
you can be Giannis and Dame I'll take my
chances against anybody if I hadn't been
to 76ers I would have said you give me
Geraldine B and Dame Lillard I'll take
my chances because you had to do
something because the Celtics when we
woke up this morning the Celtics would
have favored in the East right
when we woke up this morning we're like
yo man I think the Celtics are the team
to beat in the East when we go to bed
tonight
we're going to be saying yo man like hey
like like Chris just said the people in
Vegas they put it down smart they didn't
build a beautiful asses
they didn't build those buildings out
there in the middle of the other was 120
degrees
but when we go to bed tonight the
Milwaukee Bucks are gonna be the favor I
wish my sisters had to pull the trigger
they didn't I give the Milwaukee Bucks
credit and you know uh they're gonna be
the favorite when we go to bed tonight
so it's a great day to be a Milwaukee
Bucks fan
and like I say I'm not upset about what
my sons did but I still say the Suns and
the Lakers man that's gonna be and like
I say I don't want to sleep on the devil
necklace they got Joker but they lost a
couple of really good role players and I
you know they lost some really good role
players and they're gonna be counting on
some young kids and I don't know if
those young kids gonna be ready for that
smoke in game six seven against the Suns
and against the Lakers well Chuck
remember don't forget that uh your 76ers
started the process by trading away Drew
holiday so in case you just wanted a
little reminder of how that that all
started the process and where they are
now but but no no but first of all the
first thing they gotta do they should
have already got rid of James Hart that
that's over with but Chris they screwed
up they had a chance you know part of
your job as a team you have to make
difficult decisions that's part of your
job when they traded away they had to
choose between Jimmy Butler and Ben
Simmons and they chose wrong yeah that
was the biggest mistake that the Sixers
made if like can you imagine Geralyn
beat and Jimmy Butler I'll take my
chances that's what the Milwaukee Bucks
just said hey you know what Boston's
good the Lakers had a great summer we
didn't win the championship we got to do
something because I'm a firm believer
I'm a firm believer if you don't win the
championship you can't come back with
the same team I'm a firm believer in
that it's uh that that's just one of my
pet people like if we win the
championship can we stand Pat and ride
it out yes but if you don't win the
championship you can't stay the same and
I'm pretty sure what I think his name is
John Horst uh I think he said hey we're
not good enough and then and if we use
if we lose Giannis we're going to be
Irrelevant for the next 10 years
so lady let's go for it so I get them at
walking bucks a lot of credit it was a
great trade for them
and like I say I loved you holiday but
Drew holiday is is not gonna be Dame
Lillard plain and simple
hi Chuck final question for you got any
plans before the season starts because
you know it's back to work in a couple
of weeks yeah that's really unfortunate
Chris
hey Chris let me tell you something when
we played golf a couple weeks ago you
need you need more time on the golf
course
it was that bad Chris you was that bad
he was that bad
be Scott
I I heard four so many times
every time I I hear the ball hit the
club head and everything hit four four
four
hey man I'm just happy none of them hit
you Chuck that's awesome Chuck you
saying you guarantee his golf game is
terrible he's terrible terrible terrible
I want to thank you guys for having me
but man I gotta say something this is
gonna be you look at what the Celtics
did
you look at what the Milwaukee Bucks
just did look what my Phoenix Suns just
did you look at what the Lakers the
Lakers probably up until today had the
best off-season in the NBA
uh with all the trades and all the guys
they resigned man the Nugget the nuggets
are still the Champs until somebody beat
them you know the Warriors have had a
you know I the Warriors had a good good
off-season I think we can really get
excited about this what's going to
happen in the next year
I think so too Chuck appreciate it thank
you for stopping by and hopefully I'm
just glad none of my golf balls hit you
on of course man because that would have
been bad
[Laughter]
you know what I'm gonna have to take all
of that smoke
good stuff as always Grandpa
all right man love you guys see y'all
soon